no your options this weekend are not
limited to that home alone movie that
let's be honest none of us really care
about now we got red noticed baby a
movie that's just the contrast between
critics and audiences wow i love to see
that i don't know just cracks me up
so red noticed i never even saw a
trailer for it so i can't say like if
you saw the trip i don't know but part
way into my description you're gonna be
like oh right it's one of those movies
ryan reynolds and gal gadot they play
master thieves and the rock i always
call him the rock i get for calling
him the rock people like it's dwayne
johnson look i didn't tell him to pick
that twitter handle that's on him i say
the rock with my words but i say dwayne
johnson with my heart there but he's an
fbi agent but he gets framed so now he
and ryan reynolds have to work together
to steal these cleopatra eggs and so you
know it's the thief movie it's thieves
working with thieves and fbi agents
working with thieves to outsmart the
bigger thieves it's total 90s
thief schlock that's actually a pretty
good time i mean it has its flaws
absolutely i'll talk about as many of
them as i can but the rock and ryan
reynolds they work i feel like ryan
reynolds is getting to where i had
family members in the 90s who were like
okay i'm kind of over jim carrey movies
but i was still on the train like no i
still love jim carrey when an actor is
essentially the same character and
everything he starts wearing thin on
people and ryan reynolds is
exactly what you think he's going to be
in this movie you can't hurt that was me
i got that on etsy that said the
contrast between him and the rock the
rock being super big mr stoick and ryan
reynolds being in every sense of the
word the exact opposite they work
together and it entertains me it always
entertains me when ryan reynolds
character is just annoying the out
of someone i mean granted he'd probably
annoy me if i just wanted to get the job
done and he's just talking like if
i were in the room trying to do the job
yeah
i empathize that said in the capacity of
sitting half naked on my couch in my
robe watching a netflix movie completely
works for me
it sounded a bit differently in my head
than it came out if i don't edit that
out
i just figured you should know
and yeah at a point in watching this
movie i was like this is the 90s movie
that you're not you're supposed to take
it about as seriously as you take 90s
movies although in the world of
emulation emulation in any form whether
it be video games or
genre and decades it's never perfectly
replicated this movie has a lot more
conveniences i mean 90s movies had
conveniences maybe it's my rose-colored
goggles it has a lot of conveniences and
mcguffins to the point where they
actually use ryan reynolds to just kind
of deflect from it there's a scene where
they're looking in a room full of boxes
and ryan reynolds even makes a comment
he's like just look for the box that
says macguffin that was like
smooth deflection a little on the nose
but yeah but don't think i don't see
that and don't think the audience
doesn't either because that's exactly
what it is is a deflection but in a
simple way of entertainment flaws aside
it absolutely did its job it's like
everything 90s vomited on screen or
netflix for your enjoyment i would be
hard-pressed to find a movie that has
more conveniences than this movie has if
that bothers you look you know you more
than i know you if you need everything
to line up and you see a movie that's
trying to be too convoluted as a movie
that's trying to hide its flaws it's
flaws and conveniences that is you need
a movie like this you need a super
master thief movie to be the most
cleverly written and directed film known
to man you're not gonna like it it's as
simple as that i just can't break it
down more than that but i love me a
solid throwback and for me i was like
whoa it's like 1999 all over again and i
was actually having a good time with the
movie the movie was a fun thief
adventure it asks too much of its
audience sometimes but if you're able to
just sit back and be like yeah that was
done but hey fun ride i think
you'll enjoy it especially if you have
netflix not like you have to leave the
house that kind of that goes into it for
me that goes into part of the experience
if you have to leave the house and pay
15 bucks a ticket or whatever that
really does go into whether or not it's
like how much did i enjoy this i mean
let's be honest paying 15 bucks a ticket
to sit in an uncomfortable movie theater
chair some of them have the recliners i
know but not all of them just sitting in
this chair you got someone using their
phone down there in the front row you
got someone talking behind you or you
get to lounge around in your couch
watching a netflix movie vacuuming corn
flakes off your chest like your uncle
buck or some one of those two
scenarios just sounds more comfortable
it makes me be more lenient on movies
honestly i had a fun time with it no
alcohol required here's the real bat in
this movie you have thieves treasure
hunting takes you all across the globe
what's the over under this is a more
enjoyable uncharted movie than the
actual uncharted movie's going to be
so red notice have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you